CHRIS GROSSMEIER: Hello,
my name's Chris Grossmeier,
we'll be covering the Modeling
and Comparing Cloud Solutions
Costs and Strategy, Arc
213 session for Google.
First, quick introduction.
My name is Chris Grossmeier.
I'm Senior Director of
product for Cloud Physics
in Santa Clara, California.
I oversee the roadmap,
strategy, and the integration
of some the assessment tools
used by Google and the partners
to help customers
do assessments,
costing, and planning.
Our agenda for
today, we're going
to take a quick look at
analyzing your environment,
we're going to see how
to assess and discover
your workloads, quantifying
your data, your TCO, and what's
on premise, and take a quick
dive into planning your Cloud
migration.
And then, ultimately,
deploy and optimize.
Following the basic Cloud
migration strategy from Google.
So before we begin,
most important thing
I want to point out,
find a Cloud partner.
Most customers are
only going to succeed
when they have a strategic
partner on board who
has done this multiple times.
Take advantage of that partner,
learn from their experience,
use their resources,
and train your staff up
with these solutions.
Partners have been able
to do these services,
have direct relationships
with Google.
Take advantage of
their knowledge
and help that migration
go as smooth and as quick
the first time as possible.
Also, if you're a partner,
take advantage of the funded
assessments from Google.
If you're partner
or a user, you can
take advantage of requesting a
fully funded Google assessment
to analyze your
current infrastructure,
do the matching, do
the TCO and analysis,
and find the best output
and solution for your Cloud
migration strategy.
This can save weeks or months
for many organizations.
So as a partner, you can sign
up at the Cloud Physics site
and register.
And also for new users, you
can also request an assessment
through the customer portal or
from Cloud Physics directly.
So as you begin and you start
working with your partner,
communicate why you're
interested in exploring
the Cloud for migration.
Before you can really
advance on this journey,
what is the reason that
you're getting into the Cloud
to begin with?
How will it be used?
Production, test, staging,
dev, we want to know
are the workloads
state for stateless
and you can take
advantage of some
of the dynamics of the Cloud.
Are you going to take
advantage of Cloud services
or do you have lots
of legacy applications
you're bringing over?
So are you re-platforming
or rebuilding?
Is there a compliance
implication you're focused on?
You're trying to keep
your workloads altogether
on dedicated hardware
in a secure environment.
Or are you OK with going to
an instance based scenario?
Or do some workloads
actually really need
to stay within your
own data center?
As well as for
compliance, you need
to keep the patch management
and the resources up to date.
Is there a business impact
of this cost, as well?
Are we going to gain a
OpEx or a CapEx savings?
Can we depreciate resources?
Can we eliminate some of
the costs in the investments
that we have on premise?
Ultimately at the end,
which tier applications
are we bringing over there?
Do we need to run our most
mission critical application
in the Cloud to take
advantage of disaster recovery
and scalability or do we want
to take advantage of the Cloud
for elasticity for our
developers, or tests,
and our staging
environments and keeping
our workloads contained
and controlled
by our own organization?
So as we begin,
the very first step
in an assessment
in the GCP model
is analyze your environment.
We want to do a
quick look of what
we're going to do and
sort of define an outcome.
Like we mentioned, are
we moving to the Cloud
for a specific reason?
Are we trying to save money?
Are we trying to move
a specific outcome?
Are we trying to
re-platform an application?
Or just do an
application renewal?
By defining your outcome,
your stakeholders
have a clear compass
to know whether you're
moving in the right
direction and which
choices you should focus on.
Sole tenant, instances, Google
Cloud VMware Engine, services,
and so on.
Those are all going to have
a very unique characteristic,
and the outcome will really
help guide that scenario.
As we begin, the financial
needs are the first place
we want to begin.
On premise, we want to start
quantifying the resources
on our side first.
We'll quantify the cost of
the Cloud a little bit later,
but we need to know are we
looking at all of our resources
and what is the cost on premise.
Is it going to allow us
to do comparisons later
in the lifecycle?
So on premise, I want
to build a TCO model.
I want to quantify what
are my OpEx and CapEx
costs on premise?
And are we interested in doing a
Pay As You Go or On Demand type
model where we're paying
to keep resources on there
and then we're going to
shut them on and off,
but not getting any
significant discounts?
Or are we going to commit
to a sustained usage
or committed use discount
for some of the workloads?
There is also costs
around migration.
Are we going to have to
re-platform an application,
move it on to a new
operating system,
and spend many man hours of
actually testing and migrating
workloads?
Or can we just do a quick
motion and bring that workload
to the Cloud, knowing
that's going to work exactly
as it did on premise?
Lastly, changes in the
infrastructure at the terms
of operating systems.
If we own our own licenses,
can we bring our own licenses
to the Cloud?
Should we leverage standard
instances in the Cloud
available from the
Cloud provider?
Or should we go ahead and
leverage a free operating
system and change the model by
which we're using Oasis today?
As we begin, a key
part of this analysis
is to have a migration team.
We wanted to find who
are the stakeholders,
both at the line of business
and in IT and in the partner.
Each of you will have an
impact on the direction
that we move the applications.
We defined the
business stakeholders
and we wanted to define
the architecture team.
So as we engage in application,
we know why we're moving it.
Are we moving for
performance reasons?
Are we moving to take
advantage of certain platform?
Are we trying to get
closer to our customers?
These people are
all going to have
a say and an input
on how we migrate
and why we make
migration decisions.
So part of this TCO analysis
and the financial analysis
to look at what we have today.
We want to understand what
is the quantity of resources
we have in our data center.
What are our
servers and what are
the varying costs in age of
those resources that we've
invested in?
Do we have a
significant investment
in licenses for management,
things like multi-path,
things like operating systems,
things like virtualize storage
and virtualized network, or just
general enterprise management
as a whole?
Are we paying for additional
services on this platform?
Third party
applications that we're
using the Cloud for
today, and are those
going to be able to
carry over to the Cloud
or are those things
that will end
when we look at the end of
our on premise infrastructure?
Also, quantifying the overhead
of our infrastructure, power
and cooling, square footage,
maybe even the cost of staff
if some of them are dedicated
purely to operational
use on premise.
All of these we want to
quantify with TCO type analysis
and find out what is the cost
of our resources on premise.
Once we've done
that, we can actually
take this even further,
some of the tools,
and actually find out what
is the cost per workload?
What is the cost per VM?
What is the cost
per hour, per day,
per year for an individual
workload in our data center?
And this is going
to be very useful
as we start modeling these
resources into the Cloud model.
What metrics also matter is
going to be important for us.
We want to go through and
look at all of our workloads
and determine is
there something unique
about the characteristics
on premise
that we're trying to fix.
We want more performance
at the disk level.
We want to eliminate
contention at the CPU.
We want to eliminate memory
swapping and over-committed
hopes.
These metrics that we monitor
on premise and collect data for
are something that we
won't use as the baseline.
So as we get to
the Cloud later, we
can go back and see have
we actually improved
our performance and
actually improved
our experience for our users.
By capturing these
resources today and seeing
where the bottlenecks
and the problems are,
we can monitor those metrics
when we get to the Cloud
and do that comparison
and actually
quantify if we've
actually achieved
a significant improvement in our
availability, our performance,
or just the day
to day operations.
So once you've done
the TCO analysis
on premise, the
next part of sort
of to start planning
your Cloud migration.
We want to look at what are
the scenarios that we're
going to look at
and then use those
to build their financial costs.
We can get into a comparison
a little bit later.
So the first thing
to note, and this
is a good tip, not
everything can or should
move to the Cloud.
Filing print servers,
domain controllers.
Potentially if you have large,
hyper-converged infrastructure,
you may have infrastructure
for, such as storage arrays
and network components
that are virtualized
on premise that don't
need to move to the Cloud.
So take your time,
review the workflows
that you have on premise,
tag them, manage them,
and quantify which
ones you really
want to move to the Cloud,
which ones aren't necessary.
You may find that
there's a large portion
of your investment.
Powered off VMs, resources
that are dedicated to
on premise resources that
don't need to go to the Cloud
and can be a significant
cost savings.
So focus on what
you have locally,
work on those
resources, tag them,
and we'll use those for
filtering and reducing
our scope a bit later.
So our workload analysis.
A key part of what we have
on premise is each workload
has a defined size.
Every application owner
has come to you and said,
I want 16 or 32 processors,
I want 64 gigs of RAM,
I want all the storage.
Obviously, they have a business
need for their request.
But the reality is they may not
have ever used those resources.
Sort of right
sizing the workload
is going to be very key.
Giving the users the
opportunity to reassess
what is the ideal
size of that workload
can have a significant cost
savings for us in the Cloud.
There's a reason to pay for
32 CPU's when the workload has
never used more than four or
eight CPU's in the on premise
environment.
In addition, we want
to map these workloads
to different instances.
As we start doing analysis, the
tools that we want to leverage
today we want to
find every workload
and find out what is
the ideal workload
in that new environment.
Right sizing it first
and then mapping it
into those resources.
So we may find that instead of
16, we can get by eight CPU's.
Instead of 64 gigs of RAM,
we could get by at 24.
By mapping these instances
after the right sizing,
we can now quantify a cost for
each one of those base instance
types.
Storage has an additional level
of optimization all to its own.
Many workloads on premise have
performance characteristics
that are limited by the array.
In the Cloud, we can choose SSD
or hard drive or even optimal.
So based on the IOPS
and the throughput
of that specific
application, we may
recommend that it go to an SSD.
But the volume is large
enough or the performance
is low enough, maybe we can
put it onto a hard disk drive.
Using the tools and knowing
what the metrics are
for each workload allows
us to dynamically adjust
these on the fly.
In the end result,
we'll have a cost that's
optimized for each workload.
Lastly, there's
some choices that we
need to make around how we
want to put these on the Cloud.
Traditionally, we'd
always put resources out
there as instances
in the Google Cloud
where every operating system
got its own instance on a shared
resource in the infrastructure.
But with the event
of sole tenant nodes,
we can move our own workloads
onto a dedicated host which
is only occupied by
our own organization
and not shared
with anybody else.
To advantage a sole tenant
nodes also is over subscription.
So what if I have a lot of
idle or lightly used workloads
throughout the month?
I can oversubscribe this host,
potentially up to four to one
and gain the benefit
of over subscription
that I couldn't do with
individual instances.
And lastly, the
newly released Google
Cloud VMware Engine, allowing
us to run workloads in VMware
on Google Cloud as
a dedicated node.
Big cost savings to move
workloads just with the vMotion
from on premise to the
Cloud without having
to go through any
re-platforming or any migration.
Lastly, what are your
deciding factors?
Is it time?
Do I need to be on the
Cloud as quick as possible?
Is it I need to refresh?
Or am I re-platforming
an application
and modernizing my applications?
All these are going to be
important factors for workload
analysis.
As we start modeling,
we want to start
looking at the
characteristics that
are going to have an
impact for each instance.
Choosing a geography will have
an impact on cost immediately.
So knowing that I have a
specific geography in mind,
I can move it to wherever I want
for the maximum cost savings
or have it as close to an
end user community that
uses an application.
I can explore that sole
tenant node option,
taking advantage
of dedicated hosts.
And with dedicated
hosts, the ability
to bring my own Microsoft
licenses to the Cloud
and take advantage of my
own software assurance.
If you're a VMware
customer today
and you have a GVCE Google
Cloud Virtual VMware engine
option available to you,
move those workloads directly
into VMware in the Cloud
and potentially have
a significant savings in time
and cost of infrastructure.
But importantly, we
want to understand
what our commitments are.
As we commit to those
resources and time,
On Demand or one year
or three year commits,
we will achieve different
levels of discount
for each one of these solutions.
Lastly, understand the skills
and capability of your team,
as well.
So as I run through
this simulation
and I'm mapping my
workloads to the Cloud,
if I'm planning to move
them into instances
or I'm planning to
move them to services,
is my team or my partner
capable of doing that?
Or will I gain the advantage of
just vMotioning these workloads
into the Cloud and then learning
that skill as we go through
them one at a time,
but gain the advantage
of getting on the Cloud
as quickly as possible?
So big choice.
Jump all in or go hybrid.
If I jump all in, am I
going to do one fell swoop
and bring it all to the Cloud?
Or can I run in a
hybrid mode where
I bring specific applications
to the Cloud one at a time,
keeping some of my resources on
premise and my own data center
and run those in the Cloud
as I bring them over.
I need to understand what needs
to stay and what needs to go.
Understand the relationship
to these resources
is also important.
If lots of traffic
between two VM's,
I want to ensure that I bring
all the relevant resources
with me to the Cloud
at the same time.
So this is where we get
into discussion of what
options and impact each has.
If we adopt Google
Cloud Services,
we can see a significant savings
by taking out the operating
system in the instant causes and
focusing solely on the service.
So adopting Google
Cloud Services
for cloud SQL, SAP on
Google, Kubernetes,
any of the advanced machine
learning engines and resources
can be a significant cost
savings over running instances
for years on an
organization, giving you
true dynamic capabilities.
But I may have to do
some lift and shift.
I may have applications that
are legacy applications, Windows
2003, and those resources that
I want to bring to the Cloud.
So do I bring those applications
onto new OS instances
on the Cloud?
Or do I just migrate
that workload?
Things like
Velostrata streamline
that automation for us.
Or quickly migrate with the
Google Cloud VMware engine.
If I have a legacy
infrastructure today
and time is of the
essence, quickly
V motioning those
workloads over to the Cloud
may offer a quick advantage,
but ultimately may
mean some of these
applications remain around
much longer than you intend.
Ease of bringing it to the
Cloud doesn't necessarily
mean that it's going to end
up getting re-platformed.
When we look at the
instance options,
we want to look at
all the factors that
impact our instance choices.
Talked about right sizing, and
do we optimize those resources.
Knowing that an application
is multi-threaded and takes
advantage of multiple
CPU's, right sizing it down
may actually have an
impact on its performance.
So we definitely want to engage
with the lines of business
and the application
owners around this.
Optimizing storage
for disk type.
If we are bandwidth constrained
at the disk level, we're IO,
we're in throughput constrained,
taking advantage of SSDs
in the Cloud may give us
a significant performance
increase.
Or maybe changing the
storage model altogether.
Dev test, QA, all the
different staging,
maybe they don't need
to be on full instances.
Moving them to On Demand
or pre-emptive instances
could offer significant
savings for us
and have a big impact on
the long term strategy.
Lastly, choosing the
right instance class
is something we want to
start with right away.
Focusing on what
is it that we need.
Do we need an Intel processor
for the Intel architecture
and the Intel commands?
Am I going to go with the latest
and fastest Intel processor?
Am I going to go with
something where I really
don't know the underlying
infrastructure for cost
savings, like an E2 instance?
Or maybe I have a commitment
to an AMD solution
that's in the
infrastructure and I
know that I have an
AMD processor need.
Choosing each of these will
have a financial impact cost.
We'll reveal that through the
tools and the calculations.
Sole Tenant Nodes versus
Google Cloud VMware Engine.
A strategic choice here is that
I can over-commit Sole Tenant
Nodes and take
advantage of bringing
my own licenses over instances.
I can do the same with
the VMware Engine.
But with the VMware Engine,
I can leverage my VMware
architecture as
it is today, take
advantage of the VMware tools.
But the Google Cloud
is going to allow
me to do some functionalities
very specifically to the Cloud
without paying for the addition
of the hypervisor overhead.
If I'm not going to need
VMware in the Cloud,
maybe I don't need to bring
it to the Google Cloud VMware
Engine.
One of the key things about
Sole Tenant Nodes and the GCVE
is that I can bring my own
licenses for the Microsoft
solution.
Or I could always bring my
licenses for Linux solutions
to instances.
The limitations on
Microsoft licensing
allows me to bring
those licenses
to those dedicated OS models.
So big discussion options
around optimization
and the impact of each.
So if we're willing to
commit to resources,
we want to take advantage of
the discounts we can achieve.
If we commit to a
On Demand instance
and the workloads are
going to be out a lot,
we want to leave them on
as much as possible to gain
that sustained usage discounts.
On Demand and pre-emptive,
I will gain that advantage
for sustained use.
But if I'm willing to commit
to a year or three year,
I can get even greater savings
with that committed use
discount.
This is going to
apply to all instances
and convert them into regular
instances on the instance
model.
For the Sole Tenant
Node and the GCVE,
it's committing to
the infrastructure
over one year or three year
to maximize that savings.
So as I go through
these calculations,
I want to know
all these factors.
Could I match the
right resource?
Did I choose the right storage?
Did I choose the
right commitment?
right geography?
All those are going to play
into our scenario here.
So once we've gone
through and played
with some of the
assessment tools,
you're going to
have the capability
of doing comparisons.
We did that early TCO.
We modeled what our
cost was on premise.
We're actually able to
find that cost per VM.
We're actually able to do
that same modeling then
against the Cloud instance.
What was that cost
of that single VM
in the Cloud on a Sole Tenant
Node or as an instance?
Know your current
support services
versus future support services.
If you have resources
and people on site
and you're paying
for those on premise,
how are those going
to be impacted
if you can cut those costs?
Or are you going to be
picking up additional services
on the Cloud side?
Things like security,
logging, load balancing,
different concepts of the
infrastructure, certificate
management, and
support all are going
to play into your cost
model comparisons.
Lastly, we want to plan for
the disaster recovery scenario.
Fortunately for us, Google
takes care of the hardware
infrastructure for us.
Should a host fail,
it would bring back
the resources for us.
So I don't need to build
an N+1 or N+2 architecture.
But I do want to plan for
corruption and loss of data.
So planning for a storage and
archiving and backup scenario
is going to be key as we
get to the Cloud, as well.
Once we've done all this,
we'll collect all the data
through the assessment models.
This is where a tool, like
the Cloud Physics Analysis
is going to be critical.
We're going to bring
all of our content in
and we're going to
start prioritizing
our migration of components.
Now, key tip here, do I move
my most critical application
first?
Move the low hanging fruit.
This should be an obvious one.
We want the team to learn by
moving some of the resources
first.
Let them test and learn
how the tools work
and how they respond.
Learn for compatibility,
learn for build restrictions
and different builds
and versions that
are out there that may not be
compatible with each other.
Let them learn on the platform
by bringing that low hanging
fruit, the test
environment, the dev
environment, before you commit
to the larger enterprise.
Hopefully, a strategic partner
if they're involved with you
can give you a lot of
heads up to a lot of these.
But ultimately, you
know your applications,
you know the limits and the
requirements, and testing it
is going to be really critical
for your team to focus on
in the early stages.
So our last big
portion of the planning
is going to be deployed
optimize in the Google model.
So where we can, we want
to use the services.
If we have mail and
exchange on premise,
maybe we can take
advantage of Google Mail.
If we have exchange
servers on premise,
maybe we can use Cloud SQL.
We can take advantage
of the services that
make the most sense if we
can achieve a cost savings.
In many cases, if it's an
instance today on premise
and you can bring
it to the Cloud,
we can find a similar service
that has reduced cost.
We want to monitor
what you are consuming.
What are you using on premise?
What are you using in the Cloud?
And what was used for
certain portions of it?
Because your utilization
during migration or during peak
usage may be significantly
different throughout the year.
So if you're doing an
assessment in the off season,
understand what
you're consuming.
Optimize your resources,
that makes sense.
For your small dev tests in
QA instances or developer
desktops, making them smaller
because they're idle is fine.
But for an application
that takes advantage
that multi-threaded
environment has lots of cores,
maybe optimization isn't
critical as availability
and performance.
So understand what the business
need before you right size
or optimize those resources.
A big portion of this is
Cloud Service Integration.
If I can integrate
to a Cloud service?
Or do I want it to
be Cloud agnostic
and bring my own OS instances,
my own applications?
The tighter I get
coupled into the Cloud,
the more savings I may
be able to achieve,
but the harder it
is to move later.
And ultimately,
Kubernetes and containers,
if I'm going stateless or
I have a lot of resources
that are very dynamic
being traded on the fly,
take advantage of the new
technologies for Kubernetes.
Allow your environment
to use things like Anthos
and leverage the container
model to really save resources
as we move.
So an optimization
decision points here.
So does your staff have
the skill set now required
for Cloud management?
If they were strong
in the VMware tools,
maybe the VMware tools on
the Cloud makes more sense.
If they're really just strong
on their core applications
and the infrastructure was
not their strong point,
Cloud migration may be a very
simple choice for you to make.
The cost of migration,
lifting and shifting
resources to the
Cloud or running tools
to do a VM migration
can be very costly
versus just doing something
as simple as a vMotion.
Right sizing and re-platform
is key to the solution,
or application modernization
is key to the solution.
You're going to incur
more cost upfront.
But a vMotion will
get me on the Cloud
and get me over there quicker.
Then I can focus on the
resources in the Cloud
and not pay for that
inner region bandwidth
type scenarios.
Does your cost benefit
from Sole Tenant Nodes
or shared infrastructure?
The more I can
oversubscribed, the more
I can commit my
resources the better.
If I can oversubscribed my host
because a lot of my workloads
are relatively idle, that's
a big cost advantage.
But if my workloads are
one to one for CPU's and I
want to guarantee a commitment,
again, Sole Tenant Nodes
may offer an
advantage that I can
have my own resource,
my own host,
not shared with anybody else.
But the costs of
shared infrastructure
may be a negative in that case.
And again, operating systems.
We've touched on
this many times.
There is a significant advantage
to bringing your own operating
systems.
If you've already invested
in software assurance and you
have a multi-year agreement
with a software manufacturer
or a license manager for
the operating systems.
Bringing your own license
to the Cloud guarantees
your investment is not lost.
It allows you to bring that
resource over and reuse it.
If you own Linux,
you can do BYOL
across all instances
and all solutions.
But BYOL for Windows
environment only
applies to the Sole Tenant Nodes
and the Google Cloud VMware
Engine.
Last big choice, Will Free Do.
You may find that a lot of
the free operating systems
may be sufficient for
what you're looking for.
If I don't need an enterprise
class redhead instance
and I can get by with
a free Linux version,
it may be sufficient for some of
your non-critical applications.
So some final thoughts.
Plan, test, migrate,
learn, repeat.
This is going to be
key to the success.
Leverage that partner.
Go through these
steps multiple times.
Start with the
low hanging fruit.
Bring those resources
over the Cloud.
Learn what works and doesn't.
And then repeat and correct.
It's going to be an
important factor for bringing
these resources over.
So at that, I'm going
to say thank you.
Quick final note though,
there are resources
available from the Google team.
There is a great guide for
planning your Google Cloud
migration.
We'll get into all of the
assessment models, the tools,
and the financial
planning portions of it,
as well as Cloud Physics does
provide a full assessment
model fully funded by Google.
It's available to all partners
to offer to their customers
and for all customers to
take advantage of directly
from Google.
Visit the site, learn how to
sign up for the assessment,
and we'll guide you through
both the on premise TCO
and as well as all the Cloud
modeling for your storage,
compute, and all
the new resources
that you're looking
at in the Cloud.
With that, I want to
say thank you very much,
enjoy the rest of
the conference,
and have a good day.